Interviewer: How have you been surprised by
evolution?
Richard Lenski: Well, I think one of the things
that's really surprised me is just how long
this experiment's gone on.
When I originally
started it, I expected it to run for maybe
a year or longer. And now here we are, almost
30 years later. But within the experiment
itself there have been a lot of surprises.
One of the most exciting to me has been the
fact that we see that even after all this
time in a constant environment, the bacteria
are continuing to evolve and adapt. It's as
though there's really no limit to evolution,
and that's quite different from what I imagined
when I started the experiment. Another thing
that's gotten a lot of attention is one of
our 12 populations has gone off and evolved
this new ability to grow on citrate. It's
gone off in this new direction that none of
the other populations have gone and that other
E. coli out in nature are unable to do. So
those are a couple of the big surprises within
the experiment, and I think that they show
that when we stop and thing about evolution,
and the billions of years over which it's
happened and the vast scale of our planet,
evolution is just constantly generating a
lot of exciting new surprises.